my father was a huge smoker so at like
83 he said I got a little cancer he
called me one day and he said a little
him and my mom called and he's like I
got a little thing on my lung and I said
what are you gonna do and he goes
nothing
and I'm like why and he's like I don't
want to go through that so that was the
hardest time
processing that you're going to lose a
parent he was done living before we were
done letting him live and that's what I
learned is you got to let people live
their own life it's like we were trying
our hardest to save him and he was like
people have to want to be saved yeah
there's a lot of feelings but at the end
of the day
I'm going to tell you this make your
piece bro I can't tell you this make
your peace look in your mother's eyes
tell her you love her and then just
clean your side of the street